hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from the fiji world cup
2021 we already know who the winner is
because the last video we've shown the
game between young sister of duda and
sergey karyakin
do the wondered game very very nicely so
if you haven't seen it do check it out
in the previous video but this game in
the clash for third place uh vladimir
putin
needs to win in order to force tie
breaks against magnus carlsen and see
who will claim third place so now uh he
gets a chance but he has the black
pieces against the world champion
and uh this game uh already takes an
unknown turn very very early on in the
game uh so without further ado let's
check it out it's uh incredibly
enjoyable uh and there will be two
really cool positive video moments so
uh you know make sure you are ready for
that so uh let's check it out magnus has
the white pieces and he opens with
e4 uh and the strike back with the black
pieces fedorsif
uh decides to go for the karo khan
defense he plays c6 with d4 d5
and now magnus goes for the advanced
variation of the carl khan we have e5
uh bishop to f5 and now there are a lot
of very popular moves here knight f3
knight to c3h where he's very popular
bishop to d3 is very popular but magnus
chooses a line
that's very very rarely played and that
is c4 so already
it's very unlikely that fidosev is ready
for this
as you'll see the game takes an unknown
turn very early on
so e6 closing the chain as the bishop
has been developed and knight to c3 and
bishop to b for now pinning the knight
here magnus captures with c
captures and e5 in the center and now
this position has been reached before
but no one moves here are c
captures and e captures but the move
that fidosev plays
uh has never been played before so as of
move uh
six we have a completely new game if
plays a queen captures on d5 and okay
the knight is spin the queen can't be
captured so magnus continues development
knights the e2 the bishop is on f5 so
the knight is coming to g3
it's going to attack the knight and then
magnus will continue his development so
here
we have queen back to d8 sort of uh
losing the tempo maybe but
it's very unlikely that the queen will
be able to remain here
on on d5 you will either play bishop to
d2 or more likely you will challenge the
bishop with
a3 and then you're gonna have to capture
knight captures and then well the queen
will have to move
so queen back to d8 the other squares
are also available to the queen like
maybe d7 or a5 fedocere decides to go
back with queen to d8
and now a3 challenging the dark square
bishop we have bishop to a5
and not knight to g3 magnus attacks the
bishop here
uh we have knights the e7 now defending
saying that okay it's a relatively close
game i think the the
the knight here will be more useful than
the bishop if you want you're welcome to
grab this
light square bishop magnus says for the
moment no thank you i'm just going to
continue development
bishop to c4 and now bishop to g6 with
h4 by magnus going after h5 to attack
the light square bishop
and now h6 uh creating
a safety square for this bishop but also
weakening the f7 pawn that
might come in handy later on in the game
so magnus continues attacking it with h5
it's a very standard idea
against the carl khan just going after
this light square bishop bishop to h7
and now
queen to g4 putting pressure uh on g7
and here ferocity has to decide how to
continue
uh it's not not a very pleasant uh
position to
to meet over the board a very cool idea
is bishop to f5 because if the queen
ever captures you can always play uh
rook to
uh g8 the knight defense that square and
the bishop might
might be all right here but in the game
we have king the fa
you can never castle if you castle
bishop captures an h6 just wins on the
spot
so instead we have kinked the f8 by
fedocif and now
magnus castles and now of course you
have your light square bishop on this
diagonal the king
can never castle and it's going to be
very hard to bring this rook into the
game so magnus is preparing
f4 f5 uh sometimes in the future and
also knight is coming to e4 maybe to d6
so we'll see how black handles this so
here we have knight to d7
and now knight c to e4 right away going
after this d6 square
so bishop to c7 and now this should be
back to a2
uh we have knights to f5 bringing the
knight back into the game
and now magnus trades knight captures on
f5 and it seems like you could capture
this
with uh with the pawn and with the
double attack here but queen f3
and uh black really achieved nothing
it's just a terrible position for black
if you capture you're getting checkmated
let's not forget about our good friend
the light square bishop on a2 so after
knight captures an f5 with bishop
captures and now just queen to f3
uh and uh okay you could give up this
bishop for night if if you wanted to but
it's not going to do all that much black
does not have a clear way of developing
here and
f4 f5 is coming so after queen to f3 we
have queen to e7
bringing the queen into the game trying
to activate that queen side rook
and now knight to g3 again putting
pressure on the bishop
bishop goes back to h7 and now again
queen to g4
again getting the queen to the g file so
you can start pushing your f
pawn so here uh the biggest problem for
black is that white has this massive
center here that really
uh does not allow black to you know put
any pieces to
any decent square so of course fedocef
uh has to challenge it and he does so by
playing c5 another standard idea of
course if your opponent is attacking on
the king side you want to counter attack
in the center
so bishop to d2 avoiding this uh capture
with
uh sort of a little trick it's not it's
not much but still if you capture bishop
to b4 can be
very very annoying you're going to have
to block with knight c5 then we're going
to attack a rocket to c1 get a lot of
development in
basically for free if b6 now you're
pretty much stuck here with your
position everything here on the
this dark square diagonal and now we
push f4 f5 and we continue our attack
it is playable maybe but very very bad
but bad for black so instead we have
rooked to d8
and now comes f4 now magnus starts
pushing on the king side we have knight
to b6
and now bishop to c3 another very cool
move
uh just improving the position of this
bishop and now you definitely can't
capture here because bishop to b4 is
deadly here
so knights the d5 improving the position
of your knight it's an excellent square
uh now attacking the dark square bishop
but magnus just says all right let's go
f5
and it's a it's really really an awesome
there you did not have to allow this but
magnus says there there's no
need to you know hold back here we can
even allow knights the e3 to go after
this fork
uh and fedocef plays this but uh he's
not really going after the rook because
queen to f3 and now grabbing the rook uh
for example knight captures rook
captures is just too too strong for
for white everything is now attacking
the the black king the bishop here is a
monster
uh you can always capture here you can
push in some lines i mean
and the the light square bishop the rook
are doing nothing this bishop is doing
nothing so it's a
really a terrible position for black uh
so instead after queen to f3 we have
knight captures on f5
and not going after material here so
magnus captures on f5 with bishop
captures on f5 and now the move that
uh magnus had planned with with this
idea
and that is of course d5 preventing
black from capturing here as the bishop
on f5 would hang
so bishop to b6 uh just uh preventing
any any
uh double attack here with the d6 and
also maybe c4
check will be useful in some lines but
now
uh bishop to c4 magnus just prevents
this and
what do you play here it's a really
really ugly position the problem is
it seems like you could go for e
captures on d5 because uh okay you lose
this bishop but then you win this bishop
the problem is if e captures on d5 we
happily capture here and then if capture
is here then we play e6
and black's position is just ruined if
you play f6
then our friend the dark square bishop
here just plays
bishop captures on f6 g captures queen
g6 and that's it the rook captures on f6
is coming
and if queen to g7 trying to free up a
d7 square for the king even e7 is in the
position
this is just uh incredible if queen
captures a rook captures on f6 and
that's game over
black has to part with the queen and
white wins the game
so after bishop to c4 we have king the
g8 getting the king away from this
uh f file but uh it doesn't really help
black we have d6 by magnus
uh kind of closing your own structure
here because now the the bishops are not
all that useful
but it's going to be very very hard for
for black to
to say anything about this uh queen to
h4 and now magnus just plays
b3 the bishop was under attack and now
we have rook to d7
uh useful as now you will be able to
move your bishop the f7 pawn will be
protected
the pawns have been stopped and the the
bishop
fare is not fully operational for the
moment so how can magnus do something
about this
well he plays queen to e2 and now
what do you play here it's a very very
tricky position black has only one move
uh that kind of allows him to stay in
the game but he has to find it and that
is bishop to g4 it's a it's a very
useful move
uh because now uh well you're winning
the h5 pawn and you're sort of slowing
down the attack and if white goes for
the trade with rook to f4
then we're gonna play bishop capture
through captures and now bishop to d8
challenging the rook here so the rook
has to move and we're gonna pick up the
bishop here
uh of course uh white will capture but
he will capture with the pawn
uh so okay or you could go rook to e4
and then bishop captures rook capture
but let's say rook h3 we're gonna
capture capture and this
is kind of playable maybe you can
survive this with black it's very
difficult to play but it's definitely
the best black hat
but in the game queen the g4 was played
offering a queen trade right away
uh not indirectly and now there is a
certain move that magnus can make to
avoid
this and to start the attack so feel
free to pause the video
here and start the attack for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
going for the exchange sacrifice and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's rook captures on f5
and it seems like a move that doesn't do
all that much because you can still
trade queens the problem is
if you trade queens now uh bishop
captures and e captures on f5 it's
uh well bishop to b5 is coming attacking
the rook and after the rook moves now
we're going to play bishop to c4
and uh this bishop is completely out of
the game this rook completely out of the
game king completely out of the game
this rook is never joining the game
uh you can you can never try something
like g6 because then we play e6 and we
open up a discovery to the rook so it's
a it's a hopeless position for black
let's say you play king f8
we're gonna play rook to f1 go after
this spawn and like i said there's no
this because this
just wins the game so you could play
something like rogue d7 then we're going
to capture on f5
and you know that's it's just too ugly
position to
to play there's no playing this so
instead afterward captures on f5 fedocif
had to capture the rook and now rook to
f1
attacking the queen queen to g5 and now
comes bishop to d2 now the bishop player
has to be reactivated
and the queen now has to decide whether
you go all the way back or do you go to
h4
then we're going to attack it with rook
to f4 and then you go all the way back
so it doesn't really matter
so here queen back to d8 and now comes
queen to g4
so what do you play here there are
simply too many threats
magnus doesn't have to play queen to g
for bishop to b5
just goes after this rook this is also
sufficient uh but
after queen to g4 this is much much
cooler and now
there is really not all that much you
can play bishop to b5 is coming
and there are far more threats than just
bishop to b5 but uh
fedorsif has to try something he plays
a6 to prevent bishop to b5
but now for the second and last time
pause the video and
win this game for magnus in the coolest
way possible
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it and i know all of you were able to
do it because it simply screams uh
so congratulations to everyone the move
is of course
rook captures an f7 we remove the
defender of the e6 pawn and that's it
there's no defense here for black
king captures an f7 was played white is
threatening checkmate and there is no
good way of
defending this if rook h7 we're just
going to pick up on e6 and that's it
so here we have rook captures on f7 uh
sorry king captures on f7
you could also play rook captures on f7
but it's uh not much better
the d6 pawn is still hanging and we can
simply uh pick it up queen captures on
f6 now you have these two beautiful
pawns the rook is hanging and there's
uh well not much you can do here uh in
the game
king captures on f7 was played but now
you have to decide whether you capture
with the bishop or with the queen
and this uh this kind of reminded me of
uh
of a certain move that we discussed
during morphy's opera house game
uh where morphy could have done
something but um i don't know who
actually said it uh that it's uh
it's a butcher's move and you know
morphe is not a butcher morphe is an
artist
uh i think it was bill hearthstone in
his uh book kings of
chess but you know there there could be
a an earlier reference to the move
so here uh bishop captures uh wins uh
right away but
it's it's very crude for example king to
e8 uh and now we're going to play queen
to g6 check king of f8 and now bishop
captures on d7
and after the queen captures now we play
e6 and then of course the queen cannot
capture
the the queen will deliver checkmate so
after queen to e8 now we play e7 check
and uh well there's just this uh you
don't have a move here you have to move
the king queen captures here
and there's that so uh this is not the
so this isn't really
butchering the position it's also very
nice but the idea magnus chose is uh
uh well a bit more pleasant as you've
seen in the thumbnail so
if you have to choose between this and
that i mean if you can calculate that
both of them are winning
then it's nice to show the audience what
you can do so queen captures on e6 was
played
king to f8 and now queen to f5 check
here magnus repeats the position a few
times
to reach time control we're on move 39
so queen to g6 check king f8 queen to f5
check we've reached move 40 so uh both
players uh are
have received additional time king the
e8 queen the g6 check king to f8 and
only now e6 so the rook cannot capture
because checkmate is being delivered
uh and uh well what do you play here
queen to f6 was played
just offering a queen trade but now
comes e captures on d7
queen captures on g6 h captures on g6
and now we've reached the position from
the thumbnail look at this this pawn
guards f7 this one guards the e7 and
this pawn guards e8 there is no way
for the king or the rook uh well almost
even for the dark square bishop to enter
the game
and this is just spectacular uh fedors
have tried to activate his dark square
bishop bishop to d8 but
now magnus just uh plays a bishop to e6
and it's uh
it's a move that ensures that this rook
will not see the light of day of course
he will try to push the pawn and then
get the rook into the game via the h5
square
but as you'll see magnus has this all
worked out so h5
king to f2 we have h4 now preparing to
activate the rook
but magnus just plays bishop to g4
so no activating of the rook will be
possible uh we have b5
trying to do something on the queen side
we have king to f3 we have b4 by fedocif
a capture c captures and he was in this
position on
49 that vladimir fedoci resigned to the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh so really really a spectacular game
there there there is no useful move you
could make with black the bishop can
just make some useless moves
uh and the white really doesn't have to
do anything white can do whatever white
wants you could even march
the king like let's say here chase the
bishop away and then promote the pawn
like it's it's that simple
uh but it's it's so interesting that out
of the two options after king captures
an f7 like this wins uh you know
within let's say 10 moves but this wins
by by creating this uh
amazing position uh and it would be a
shame if we did not have this position
on the board here just you know
controlling everything and not allowing
the black to activate any of the pieces
so magnus had uh quite a more enjoyable
time
uh in the clash for third place than in
his semi-final match against duda duda
really did a number on him but also won
against sergey karjakin duda wins the
the
the affiliate world cup 2021 uh karjakin
wins second place and magnus wins
third place so uh as magnus is the world
champion
uh he will not be in the in the candace
tournament but he might be if he loses
the
uh the world championship match against
nepo he is automatically drafted into
the
feeder candidates uh tournament and uh
there he will of course meet everyone
else who qualified
alongside uh young [ __ ] of duda and
sergey karjakin
so really awesome game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh and yeah
this is it for the world cup hope you
guys enjoyed this short coverage we are
now returning to the morphe saga and i
am planning to
you know put put an end to it and you
know finish the
the morphe saga we've been uh going over
it for for over a year now but it's uh
it's just the the
uh the way the the modern chess works
there are simply
so many events so many events great
events are even overlapping so you can't
even cover all of them it's hard to
follow all of them
uh so when i started the sagas there
really wasn't all that much happening in
the chess world
and i could you know devote a lot of
time to a certain saga like when we did
the mikael tal saga or the bobby fischer
saga
uh but nowadays there's simply too much
chess going on so i will finish the
morphe saga but
in the future i will try to make uh the
saga is a bit shorter maybe i'm going to
make like
10 videos that if we if we're going to
cover an entire life of a certain player
i'm going to try and make it a bit more
concise
10 videos with with 10 of the best games
and you know something about their lives
uh
maybe something like that but we'll
we'll see how it goes
uh but yeah that's it for this video
hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank tom derelow uh
alexander trebus brandon fukuda uh arnie
fox and
yo mariju for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day